there are some guys when they shoot it's
almost like they punching you the ball
is going through the net and you feel
like man this dude just like just
slapped me with the jump shot you know
[Music]
lillard beating away the three
deep fade away three
this is for the win he knocks it down
so when you talk about damian lillard
the first thing that you really notice
about him is his shot making the
distance that he shoots but also his
ability to shoot off the bounce that's
the thing that really separates a lot of
guys can you get your shot off the
dribble with defense on you people say
you know that's one of the first time
we've seen a player like this shoot from
this distance with this type of rain
this type of bounce well i hate to burst
everybody's bubble a little bit because
i'ma remind you of another guy who did
it just as well and his name was mahmoud
abdul rahoof
[Applause]
there it is
it still works every single game fakes
pulls up take back blue edwards
now when you talk about macmu you talk
about somebody who had the one two in
terms of between the legs the crossover
then to pull up but he had it
all kinds of ways it was difficult to
guard my move because his off-the-bounce
dribble was so tight and then it was so
quick and then he had a shot fake built
into it it was a a one two
fake let you go by then knock it down
and then it was a one two shot and all
of it was like in the same cadence and
same rhythm it's like a great pitcher
throwing a fastball and then he gives
you the change up with the same motion
and you way out in front of the pitch
you know instead of pitch coming 100
miles an hour
now it's coming 82. well that was my
move my move shot would be a hundred and
then he'll visit and nice 82 and you
flying by and he looking at you and you
go
out to mockmore for
yes
up at the top for three yes
he's five out of five there's a three
with two guys on him good again
unbelievable
this this is a record performance here
by mahmoud tonight
so mahmoud is playing against john
stockton one of the greatest guards ever
played and mahmoud gives stockton
51.
51. unbelievable that's how great a
shooter he was and that's how good he
is going to pull three and it's good
puff fake settles for the three
[Applause]
[Music]
a two-point lead when i'm watching
lillard the reason why in terms of
shooting the basketball off the dribble
he reminds me a lot of my move is
because of the moxie that he has with
his shot the force that he has with his
shots some guys will shoot and it's real
pretty and it's beautiful it rolls up in
the air like larry bird had a beautiful
shot and it just kind of like danced in
the air and then there are some guys
like a kobe or dame or macmu when they
shoot it's almost like they punching you
the ball is going through the net and
you feel like man this dude just like
like just slapped me with the jump shot
you know so i just want to remind
everybody that this isn't the first time
that you've seen this type of action
what's old is new again and macmoon is
still new
mahmoud
i hope everybody goes back
watch a little film of you and give you
the proper due and respect that you
deserve for being one of the greatest
shooters to ever come in our league